♪♪♪♪♪
>> CYCLE 16 OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS MORE THAN HALFWAY OVER.
NEXT WEEK,
THE REMAINING FIVE GIRLS
ARRIVE IN MOROCCO,
AND SOON, ONE LUCKY GIRL
WILL HAVE HER CAREER LAUNCHED
IN ITALIAN "VOGUE,"
AND NOT JUST WITH ONE,
BUT TWO FASHION SPREADS
AND THE COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE."
AND DID I MENTION
THAT SHE'LL ALSO RECEIVE
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL?
YOU'RE HOME!
>> (screaming)
>> BEGINNING WITH A HUGE TWIST
WHEN THE GIRLS SHOWED UP
FOR CASTING WEEK,
SO FAR, IT'S BEEN
ONE DRAMATIC CYCLE
OF "A.N.T.M."
>> (gasps)
>> DON'T TALK TO ME LIKE THAT.
>> HOW YOU TALK TO ME
IS ANNOYING.
>> AND I DON'T GIVE A DAMN
WHAT YOU THINK OF ME.
>> BUT IF YOU MISSED ANYTHING,
YOU'RE IN LUCK,
BECAUSE TONIGHT,
WE'RE GONNA CATCH YOU UP ON
ALL THE FIERCE FASHION EVENTS
AND ALL THAT OTHER FREAKY STUFF
THAT YOU DID NOT GET TO SEE
ALONG THE WAY...
IS SOMETHING HAPPENING?
>> I NEED MY MOM.
>> (cries) ENOUGH. OH, (bleep).
>> AND WE'LL CHECK IN
ON CYCLE 15's WINNER, ANN.
SO DON'T GO AWAY, Y'ALL.
THE CYCLE 16 MID-SEASON RECAP
BEGINS NOW.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
>> THIS CYCLE, WE DID AWAY
WITH THAT SAME OLD CASTING WEEK
IN ORDER TO GET
RIGHT INTO THE COMPETITION
ON DAY ONE.
AND IN CASE YOU MISSED
THOSE PANELS,
HERE'S A LOOK BACK
ON SOME VERY INTERESTING GIRLS
THAT DID NOT MAKE THE CUT.
(squeals)
MY FAVORITE DESIGNER
IS HELLO KITTY.
WHOO!
I CAN SMIZE, LIKE, WITH MY EYES.
I'M DOING IT.
MY NAME IS ANGORA NYLANDRA
TAFATIA MICHAELS.
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
WHAT DO I HAVE
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS DON'T HAVE?
HELLO?
LOOK, LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE.
I
AMMY ART.
I'M NOT A COOKIE CUTTER.
I CUT THE COOKIES,
AND I'LL CUT YOU.
BETTER LUCK NEXT TIME, LADIES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I BROUGHT OUT 32 GIRLS
TO L.A...
>> (screaming)
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
BUT THIS TIME,
WE MADE OUR DECISIONS
BEHIND THE SCENES.
BEFORE TELLING THEM,
WE DECIDED TO THROW
A LITTLE CURVEBALL,
TO SEE WHAT THESE GIRLS
ARE REALLY MADE OF.
>> GO AHEAD. OPEN 'EM.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING ELSE,
AND I JUST WASN'T IT,
SO IT DOESN'T MEAN
I'M GONNA STOP.
>> BUT DON'T WORRY.
WE LET 'EM OFF THE HOOK
QUICKLY.
SO UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU GUYS HAVE TO GO HOME NOW,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO FAR...
BECAUSE YOU'RE HOME!
>> (screaming)
>> YOU GUYS ARE THE 14!
>> WHOO!
>> THE CAST OF CYCLE 16
MOVED INTO
THEIR NEW PENTHOUSE LOFT
ON DAY ONE OF THE COMPETITION.
>> (growls)
>> (screaming)
>> MINE!
>> OH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
LOOK AT OUR BATHROOM!
WHOO! WHOO!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
OH, MY GOD. IT'S A CLOSET.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WE SAW THIS ZEBRA
AND THIS LEOPARD
AND THIS ANIMAL JUNGLE THING,
AND IT WAS KIND OF LIKE,
WHERE ARE WE?
>> THIS IS MINE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> ONCE EVERYONE WAS
SETTLED IN,
WHAT YOU NEVER SAW WAS
RESIDENT HIPPIE HANNAH
WORKING HER MAGIC CRYSTAL.
>> LOOK AT THIS, GUYS.
>> THAT'S 'CAUSE, LIKE...
>> I'M NOT DOING ANYTHING.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> I HAVE A PENDULUM.
IT'S A LITTLE CRYSTAL
THAT HANGS ON A METAL CHAIN.
I WAS, LIKE,
CHECKING PEOPLE'S CHAKRAS.
WE HAVE THEM ALL UP OUR BODY,
AND I THINK IT ALSO
HAS TO DO WITH YOUR AURA.
SHOW ME "YES."
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> SHOW ME "NO."
>> IT MOVED ON ITS OWN,
SWEAR TO GOD.
>> IT WENT FROM SPINNING
TO SWINGING.
IT WAS INSANE.
>> AAH!
>> SO WE STARTED CHECKING, LIKE,
OTHER CHAKRAS POINTS
ON THE BODY.
>> YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
(laughs)
(record needle scratches)
>> OH, MY.
>> NO, DO JACLYN! DO JACLYN!
COME ON!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE WANT TO DO
AN EXPERIMENT ON YOU.
>> CAN WE DO
AN EXPERIMENT ON YOU?
>> I WAS SOUND ASLEEP,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE GIRLS RUN IN THERE,
AND THEY GET ME OUT OF BED,
THEY LAY ME ON THE TABLE,
AND HANNAH GETS OUT
HER VOODOO-LOOKIN'
CRYSTAL BALL THING.
>> DON'T MOVE.
>> OH, IT'S GOING IN A CIRCLE.
>> AND THEY WERE TRYING TO SEE
WHAT IT WOULD DO--
SINCE I'M A VIRGIN--
TO SEE IF IT WOULD SHAKE.
>> OH, MY GOSH, JACLYN.
>> JACLYN!
>> JACLYN...
(speaks indistinctly)
>> I WAS VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
LAYING ON THAT TABLE.
IT WAS KINDA AWKWARD
'CAUSE WE EAT ON THAT TABLE.
I'M GOING BACK TO BED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG
BEFORE DOMINIQUE
RALLIED THE MODELS
TO PUT THEIR NEW RUNWAY
TO GOOD USE.
>> I'M GONNA GIVE YOU GUYS
A CHALLENGE.
I WANNA SEE YOU WORK
YOUR RUNWAY.
BUT, UM, WE HAVE
ONE MORE SURPRISE FOR YOU.
YOU'RE NOT JUST ROCKING
THE RUNWAY IN CLOTHES.
IT'S PAPER BAGS!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE ALL KIND OF, LIKE,
INVENTED OUR OWN LITTLE OUTFITS.
BASICALLY, WE MADE THEM
OUT OF PAPER BAGS.
>> AAH!
>> WE DID THIS RUNWAY SHOW,
AND IT WAS AMAZING.
SARA AND MYSELF AND NICOLE
WERE ALL JUDGES.
AND DOMINIQUE WAS
BOTH MISS J. AND MR. JAY.
>> OH!
>> (imitating Miss J.) WHEN DID
WE START WALKING BACKWARDS?
HONEY, CHILD, I DON'T KNOW.
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD. SEE THAT WAVE?
>> THE FIRST CHALLENGE
OF CYCLE 16 WAS ALSO A RUNWAY,
BUT THIS RUNWAY WAS
JUST 12 INCHES WIDE,
AND INSTEAD OF MODELING
PLASTIC BAGS,
THE GIRLS HAD TO WORK
SOME PLASTIC BUBBLES.
>> (screaming)
>> BUT FIRST, THE GIRLS HAD
A BACKSTAGE PHOTO SHOOT WITH
THE ONE AND ONLY RUSSELL JAMES.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
RUSSELL WAS TRYING TO CAPTURE
THOSE SEEMINGLY CANDID MOMENTS
AS MODELS GET READY
BEFORE A FASHION SHOW.
>> GORGEOUS THERE.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> BOTH MOLLY AND BRITTANI
MADE IT SEEM EFFORTLESS.
>> JUST LOOK TO ME HERE,
SWEETIE.
>> MEANWHILE, DOMINIQUE
AND ANGELIA STRUGGLED
WITH BEING NATURAL
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
AFTER THE SHOOT,
THE GIRLS PUT ON
A SLIGHTLY MORE DIFFICULT
FASHION SHOW THAN THE ONE
FROM THE NIGHT BEFORE.
LET'S JUST SAY THERE WERE
SOME TROUBLE BUBBLES.
I MEAN, BUBBLE TROUBLE.
>> (gasps)
>> WHOO!
>> OH!
>> I ROLLED MYSELF
AND THEN GOT UP.
>> YOU HAD TO GET UP
BY YOURSELF?
>> YEAH.
>> OHH! SHUT UP!
>> OH!
>> (cheering)
>> AT THE FIRST PANEL,
DOMINIQUE AND ANGELIA
FOUND THEMSELVES IN THE BOTTOM.
BUT IT WAS ANGELIA
WHOSE PHOTO FAILED
TO SAY "MODEL,"
AND SHE WAS ELIMINATED.
COMING UP,
ONDREI FALLS OUT.
ONDREI, ARE YOU OKAY?
IS SOMETHING HAPPENING?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> GIRL, ARE YOU OKAY?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IN THIS
NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN FOOTAGE,
AMERICA'S SWEETHEART,
MISS JACLYN,
TURNS THE BIG 2-0.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
>> OH! THANK YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> I WOULD PICK A CARD
OVER ANYTHING.
>> JACLYN--I WANNA PUT HER
IN MY BAG
AND JUST CARRY HER AROUND
LIKE A PUPPY.
LIKE, SHE'S SO (bleep) CUTE.
>> I DON'T WANNA CRY.
>> JACLYN IS
THE SWEETEST LITTLE BABY EVER.
I'M NOT PATRONIZING HER AT ALL,
BUT, UM, SHE--SHE'S LIKE...
(high-pitched voice) I WANNA BE
A WOMAN!
>> YOU ONLY TURN 20 ONCE.
I'M GONNA BE A REAL WOMAN.
I'M A WOMAN NOW.
AND I'M A BEAUTIFUL,
STRONG YOUNG WOMAN.
>> JACLYN MAYTHINK
SHE'S A WOMAN NOW...
>> DANG IT!
>> BUT SHE REVERTED
RIGHT BACK INTO A CHILD
WHEN FACED WITH HOUSEKEEPING.
>> I NEED MY MOM.
I CAN'T MAKE MY BED.
MONIQUE!
I NEED YOU
TO HELP ME MAKE MY BED!
>> JACLYN IS KIND OF
GETTING ON MY NERVES.
>> MONIQUE!
>> CAN YOU WAIT A...
(bleep) SECOND?
SHE WAS PROBABLY
A VERY SHELTERED CHILD,
UM, GROWING UP.
AND, I MEAN, SHE'S 20 YEARS OLD.
YES?
>> I NEED YOU TO HELP ME
PUT MY SHEETS ON MY BED.
>> DUDE, I HATE PUTTING SHEETS
ON BEDS.
>> I CAN'T GET THESE ON HERE.
>> I WASN'T EVEN GONNA
PUT MINE ON.
SHE HAS A REALLY CUTE LOOK,
BUT I DON'T THINK
SHE IS STRONG ENOUGH TO MAKE IT.
>> I CAN'T GET THESE
ON HERE RIGHT.
>> WHILE JACLYN WAS CONCERNED
WITH BECOMING A WOMAN,
MONIQUE WAS WORRIED ABOUT
HAVING A LITTLE TOO MUCH
WOMANLY APPEAL.
>> IT SOUNDS SO FUNNY,
BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO NOT BE SEXY, I GUESS.
(laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> YOU KNOW, YOU GOT BODY,
YOU GOT ALL THIS KINDA GOING ON,
AND THERE'S A LOT TO PLAY WITH.
>> SINCE THE J's
KEEP TELLING ME, LIKE,
"HEY, MISS SEXY,"
AND I'M LIKE, OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
LIKE, I GOTTA WORK ON THAT.
IT'S NOT, LIKE,
A REAL COMPLIMENT.
TRYING TO MODEL AND BE CURVY,
IT'S (bleep) HARD.
>> I DON'T THINK MONIQUE'S
GONNA MAKE IT THE WHOLE WAY
SOLELY BECAUSE SHE IS TOO SEXY.
YOU HAVE, LIKE, THE BEST BODY
I'VE EVER SEEN
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
>> SHH. NO WAY.
>> SHE TOLD ME HERSELF
SHE WANTS TO DO
VICTORIA'S SECRET,
AND WE'RE NOT HERE
TO DO VICTORIA'S SECRET.
WE'RE HERE TO DO
ITALIAN "VOGUE."
>> MONIQUE IS JUST, LIKE,
SO VOLUPTUOUS.
LIKE, SHE HAS ALL THE ASS
FOR DAYS.
>> HAVING, LIKE, A BOOTY
IS JUST KIND OF, LIKE...
IT'S JUST KIND OF STRESSFUL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
HAD EVERYBODY BUZZING,
AS THE GIRLS POSED
IN JEWELRY COVERED IN LIVE BEES
TO CAPTURE AN EDGY BEAUTY SHOT.
(buzzing)
>> GOOD.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
IT'S STUNNING!
>> MONIQUE AND KASIA
IMPRESSED JAY
WITH THEIR STRONG POSES
AND PIERCING EYE CONTACT
DESPITE THOSE
DISTRACTING LITTLE INSECTS.
MEANWHILE, NICOLE'S SHOOT
LACKED ENERGY...
>> HEY, NICOLE, YOUR EYES
LOOK EXTREMELYSLEEPY.
>> OKAY.
>> IT'S LIKE, "IS SHE AWAKE?"
AND ONDREI SEEMED LOST,
AS IF HER ATTENTION
WERE ELSEWHERE.
>> HEY, ONDREI.
>> YES?
>> YOU ARE JUST
GOING THROUGH THE MOTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
>> DURING THE PHOTO SHOOT TODAY,
I WAS JUST, LIKE,
I WAS HERE, BUT I WASN'T HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> BACK AT THE LOFT,
ONDREI CONFIDED THAT SHE WAS
HAVING A HARD TIME
COPING WITH THE RECENT DEATH
OF HER BROTHER
AND THAT SHE WAS DEBATING
WHETHER OR NOT
TO LEAVE THE COMPETITION
TO BE WITH HER FAMILY.
>> YOU WANNA MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
>> BUT DURING A TEACH
THE NEXT DAY,
THE PRESSURE GOT TO BE
TOO MUCH FOR HER.
>> YOU'VE JUST LEARNED TODAY,
YOU CAN EAT REALLY GOOD FOOD
AND YOU CAN FEEL YOUR BEST.
>> ONDREI, ARE YOU OKAY?
IS SOMETHING HAPPENING?
>> ARE YOU OKAY, ONDREI?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> GIRL, ARE YOU OKAY?
>> ONDREI IS, LIKE,
LAYING ON THE GROUND,
AND I'M LIKE,
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> YOU FEEL HOT?
CAN I TAKE THIS OFF?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HECK
HAPPENED TO ME.
AND I HAVE NEVER FAINTED
IN MY WHOLE ENTIRE LIFE,
BUT I DID THEN.
>> OKAY, I'M GONNA CALL
A DOCTOR THOUGH, OKAY?
I WANT A DOCTOR TO SEE YOU,
OKAY?
>> I'M JUST MAINLY
A LITTLE WORRIED
'CAUSE SHE DOESN'T LOOK SO GOOD.
>> (speaks inaudibly)
>> ONDREI'S NERVES SEEMED TO BE
GETTING THE BEST OF HER,
SO AT PANEL,
SHE TOLD THE JUDGES
SHE WAS READY TO GO HOME,
BUT THERE STILL WAS
AN ELIMINATION TO FACE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, NICOLE'S
MATURE-BEYOND-HER-YEARS
APPEARANCE IN HER PHOTOS WAS
JUST NOT INSPIRING THE JUDGES,
AND NICOLE WAS SENT HOME.
SARA WAS DEFINITELY
A CHARACTER THIS CYCLE.
>> (imitates Ozzy Osbourne)
SHARON!
(normal voice) I AM A WOMAN.
I HAVE HAIRY LEGS.
THAT'S HOW IT IS.
HI, MONIQUE. GOOD MORNING.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> SHE'S THE TYPE
OF UNIQUE GIRL
WITH AN UNUSUAL LOOK
THAT ILOVE FOR "TOP MODEL,"
AND THE GIRLS ALL LOVED
HER QUIRKS...
WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF DOMINIQUE,
WHO COULD NOT GET PAST
HER TRADEMARK FINGER WAG.
(squeaking)
>> I REALLY WANNA TRY
THAT STEAMY STUFF
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> I'VE SEEN THAT.
>> YEAH, IT'S LIKE A--
>> LOOKS LIKE A LITTLE WORM,
LIKE, WHAT THE (bleep)?
SARA IS...
(sighs) DIFFERENT.
I'M GONNA TELL YOU,
YOU LOOK A LITTLE STUPID.
>> DOMINIQUE, WHEN YOU DO
THE WHOLE, "I'M SO DOMINIQUE,
AND I CAN DO THIS,
AND I DON'T NEED YOU,
AND BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
YOU LOOK STUPID," IT'S MEAN.
DON'T BE MEAN.
I'M A CLOWN.
I LIKE TO MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH.
BUT IF YOU'RE JUST TALKING
(bleep) TO ME AND YOU JUST
WANT TO START SOME TROUBLE,
YOU'RE GONNA GET TROUBLE,
AND IT'S GONNA COME
WITH A TABLE LEG.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
DOMINIQUE, I REALLY LIKE YOU
AS PERSON, AND WHEN YOU DO THAT,
IT MAKES ME WANT TO KICK YOU
IN THE VAGINA.
>> DON'T KICK ME IN THE VAGINA
BECAUSE I WILL KICK YOU
IN YOUR HEAD.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HEY, WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
>> AS MAKEOVERS DREW NEAR...
>> (screaming)
>> THE TALK SURROUNDING
EVERYONE'S LOOKS
TOOK OVER THE HOUSE.
>> MOLLY IS SOHIGH MAINTENANCE.
>> MY FEET ARE DIRTY,
AND I LOOK NASTY.
UGH. MY SKIN--
IT'S SO BUMPY.
REALLY, REALLY HOT.
>> IF MOLLY DOESN'T LIKE
HER HAIRCUT,
SHE'S GONNA BITCH ABOUT IT
FOREVER.
>> WHEN THE DAY ARRIVED,
AS HANNAH HAD WORRIED,
MOLLY HAD DIFFICULTY
WITH ONE OF
THE MOST CHALLENGING
MAKEOVER LOOKS
IN "TOP MODEL" HISTORY.
>> IF I DON'T GET THIS (bleep)
TAKEN OUT OF MY HEAD TOMORROW,
THERE'S GONNA BE
A (bleep) STORM.
I WILL RIP IT OFF
OF MY (bleep) HEAD.
>> BUT IT WAS ALEXANDRIA
WHO PROVED HIGH MAINTENANCE.
>> THERE'S SOME FLAT PIECES
AND THERE'S
SOME SQUISHED ROUND PIECES.
THERE'S--I KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO LOOK LIKE.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
PERFECTLY ROUND,
WHERE THEY'RE, LIKE, BEADS.
>> WHO DOES THAT?
LIKE, THEY'RE THE HAIRDRESSER,
NOT YOU.
>> IT'LL BE FINE.
>> I DON'T LIKE FAKE HAIR,
AND I WANT IT TO BE LOOKING OKAY
IF IT IS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AND FINALLY,
THE REAL SUCCESS OF THE DAY
WAS BRITTANI'S NEW CHIC BOB.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
(camera shutter clicks)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
SHOWCASED THE MODELS' MAKEOVERS
AS WELL
AS SOME FASHION COUTURE
AND WAS STYLED BY
THE INFINITELY TALENTED
LORI GOLDSTEIN
AND SHOT BY
THE INCREDIBLE PAMELA HANSON.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NOT ONLY WERE THE CLOTHES
EXTRA SPECIAL THIS DAY,
BUT AS ALWAYS,
LORI WORKED HER MAGIC,
SPENDING EXTRA TIME
WITH EACH AND EVERY GIRL,
PERFECTING THEIR LOOKS.
>> WHAT DO WE HAVE
THAT WOULD POUF THIS OUT?
I WOULD REALLY WANT THIS
TO COME OUT HERE.
SO THE VOLUME'S
WHAT'S GONNA MAKE THIS PICTURE.
OKAY, GO.
YOU LOOK FABULOUS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> DESPITE HER DISAPPOINTMENT
ABOUT HER HAIR,
MOLLY CAME THROUGH BEAUTIFULLY
IN HER SHOOT WITH KASIA.
>> I LIKE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE,
MOLLY.
IT'S GOOD.
>> RIGHT NOW,
MOLLY HAS DEFINITELY OVERCOME
HER MAKEOVER ORDEAL.
>> THAT'S NICE, MOLLY.
>> AND ALTHOUGH
ALEXANDRIA SEEMED TO NEED
AN ATTITUDE ADJUSTMENT...
>> LET ME SEE.
>> NO. (scoffs)
(camera shutter clicks)
>> SHE AND MONIQUE DELIVERED
ON ONE GREAT SHOT
AFTER ANOTHER.
>> I THINK WE HAVE THIS.
AWESOME.
>> MEANWHILE, IT WAS DOMINIQUE
WHO COULD NOT KEEP UP
WITH HER PARTNERS THAT DAY.
>> DOMINIQUE, I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WORST THING
A MODEL COULD NOT HAVE
IS INSPIRATION.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
AT PANEL, THE JUDGES AGREED
THAT DOMINIQUE WAS
NOT PROVING HERSELF
DYNAMIC ENOUGH
TO CUT IT AS A TOP MODEL,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
COMING UP,
ALEXANDRIA BUSTS A RHYME.
>> ♪ I'M NOT A CHUMP ♪
♪ I'M A CHAMP ♪
♪ AND I'M IN IT TO WIN IT ♪
♪ WORD, GOT THAT ♪
♪ NATURAL-BORN SWAGGER ♪
♪ BEST NEVER FORGET IT, WORD ♪
>> THE GIRLS WERE ON FIRE
AT THE NEXT RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
NO, LITERALLY ON FIRE.
>> YOU WILL BE WALKING
WITH YOUR HANDS
ACTUALLY ON FIRE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING
FLAMES IN OUR HANDS.
THAT'S CRAZY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (blows)
>> BRITTANI, MOLLY, AND DALYA
LOOKED SMOKING HOT
ON THAT CATWALK...
BUT KASIA AND SARA WERE
RUNNING ON FUMES THAT NIGHT,
AND MISS J. WAS NOT PLEASED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FOR THEIR NEXT SHOOT,
THE GIRLS TURNED ACTRESSES,
SELLING FIERCE ROAST COFFEE
IN A CAMPY,
'60s-THEMED COMMERCIAL
DIRECTED BY
SEXY FRANCESCO CARROZZINI.
>> QUIET ON THE SET.
>> A-B MARK.
>> ACTION.
>> DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST COFFEE
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> (gulps)
>> AND MARK.
>> ACTION.
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER
THAN ANY OTHER COFFEE
ON THE MARKET?
(beep)
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
(beep)
>> KASIA ROSE
TO THE OCCASION LIKE A PRO,
REDEEMING HERSELF
AFTER HER LOSS
AT THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> CUT.
VERY GOOD, KASIA.
>> THANK YOU.
(beep)
>> PAIRED WITH BRITTANI,
ALEXANDRIA TOOK CONTROL
OF THEIR GROUPAND THE SET
AND ANYTHING ELSE
SHE SAW FIT TO MANAGE.
>> SHE WAS BUSY
DOING FRANCESCO'S JOB.
SHE WAS DOING MY JOB.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT
WE GOT A SHOT OF US
POURING THE COFFEE, THOUGH.
SHOULD I JUST HAVE MY HAND,
THOUGH, TAKING IT AWAY
RIGHT THERE?
DON'T LOOK BACK OVER HERE
'CAUSE I'M NOT THERE ANYMORE.
>> THEN SHE'S, LIKE,
CHECKING THE LIGHTING.
I SWEAR, THE GAFFERS WERE
ALMOST NERVOUS THAT ALEXANDRIA
WAS CHECKING OUT THE LIGHTS.
>> I WAS REALLY JUST TRYING
TO HELP OUT.
>> I KNOW BUT IF YOU DO THAT
ON A REAL COMMERCIAL,
THEY'RE GONNA TELL YOU
TO GO--GO HOME.
(beep)
>> MEANWHILE, SARA STRUGGLED
WITH THE THEME OF THE DAY
AND COULD NOT GET
INTO CHARACTER.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> SARA, WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I'M FINDING IT REALLY HARD
TO FAKE ANY SORT
OF SEXUAL ENERGY AND/OR MOTION.
I'VE NEVER HAD TO FAKE
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN MY LIFE.
WILL SARA AND ALEXANDRIA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> AT THE NEXT ELIMINATION,
THE JUDGES AGREED
THAT SARA'S PERFORMANCE
IN THE COMMERCIAL WAS
THE WORST OF THE DAY.
AND Y'ALL KNOW HOW IT GOES.
SARA WAS SENT HOME.
>> (laughs)
>> NOW NO ONE WOULD KNOW
BY JUST LOOKING AT HER
THAT KASIA IS ACTUALLY
THE OLDEST GIRL
IN THE COMPETITION.
>> I'M 26,
BUT NOBODY EVER BELIEVES ME
BECAUSE I DO LOOK A LOT YOUNGER.
LIKE, I DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE ME AND BE LIKE,
"SHE'S 26."
>> YOU'RE 26?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE,
LIKE, 19 OR 20.
>> NO WAY.
>> I AM IN TOTAL SHOCK.
SHE HAS A YOUNGER FACE.
>> MOST OF THE GIRLS TOLD ME
THEY THOUGHT I WAS YOUNG--
LIKE, WHEN THEY FIRST MET ME,
THEY THOUGHT I WAS
ONE OF THE YOUNGER ONES,
AND IT WAS, LIKE,
SHOCKING TO THEM.
>> SHE DOES NOT LOOK THAT OLD
AT ALL.
>> I KNOW.
>> I HAD NO IDEA.
>> YEAH, 26.
>> I WOULD'VE GUESSED 20, 21.
>> 26 YEARS OLD.
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW OLD SHE IS?
SHE'S 26,
AND SHE HAS THE BEST SKIN
OUT OF ALL OF US.
>> SO HOW DOES SHE KEEP
HER SKIN SO PERFECT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WELL, I DRINK
TONS OF WATER ALL THE TIME.
TWO NIGHTS A WEEK,
I EXFOLIATE.
THEN I WILL PUT A SERUM ON
OR SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE POTENT,
THEN A GOOD EYE CREAM.
SOMETIMES I PUT
A LITTLE VITAMIN E OIL
ON MY FACE.
SO JUST, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> AND I'VE ASKED HER,
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"OH, I USE DIFFERENT THINGS."
IF I USED DIFFERENT THINGS
ON MY FACE EVERY NIGHT,
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY PIMPLES
I WOULD HAVE?
I HATE HER.
(chimes play)
>> THE MODELS HAD
A COVERGIRL CHALLENGE,
WORKING IN GROUPS
TO COME UP WITH
THEIR OWN ONLINE VIDEOS,
HIGHLIGHTING THE LATEST
AND THE GREATEST PRODUCTS.
EACH GIRL
WAS ASSIGNED A ROLE.
AND ALMOST EVERYBODY
WORKED WELL TOGETHER.
(record needle scratches)
>> WELL, THEN DO IT.
IF YOU'RE GONNA--
TRYING TO WRITE THE WHOLE THING,
JUST DO IT.
>> NO, I'M NOT TRYING TO...
CAN YOU JUST LET ME PRACTICE,
PLEASE?
>> WELL...
>> WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A TEAM.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING US BE A TEAM, DUDE.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO LEARN
MY LINES, AND YOU GUYS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING, TOO.
>> YEAH, AND WHEN WE ASK YOU
SOMETHING OR TRY
TO TALK ABOUT IT,
YOU'RE LIKE, "SHUT UP."
(two gunshots)
>> BUT WHAT YOU NEVER SAW WAS
THE DIRECTORS GETTING TOGETHER
BACK HOME TO TALK
A LITTLE SMACK
ABOUT THEIR TEAMS.
>> THEN SHE STARTS FREAKING OUT,
AND SHE'S LIKE, "YOU'RE
MAKING ME LOOK LIKE A BITCH."
I'M LIKE,
"YOU'RE ACTING SNOTTY."
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO LEARN
MY LINES, AND YOU GUYS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING, TOO.
>> YEAH, AND THEN WHEN WE ASK
YOU SOMETHING OR TRY TO...
>> JUST STAND UP AND HELP ME.
>> WE HAVE TRIED TO HELP YOU
ALL THE TIME.
>> AND THEN WHEN WE ASK YOU
SOMETHING OR TRY TO TALK
ABOUT IT, YOU'RE LIKE,
"LET ME LEARN MY LINES,"
AND YOU GET SNAPPY WITH US.
>> DALYA LOOKED GREAT AND SHE
WAS REHEARSING SO WELL WITH US,
BUT AS SOON AS, LIKE,
THE CAMERA STARTED ROLLING...
(sighs) IT JUST FELL APART.
>> YEAH.
>> SHE JUST STARTED, LIKE,
VOMITING FROM THE MOUTH,
AND, LIKE, JUST TRYING
TO SELL IT SO HARD.
>> YOU TOLD ME
"DON'T SAY 'BOLD,'" THOUGH.
>> IT'S--
THAT'S WHAT THE PRODUCT IS.
ME AND JACLYN
TOTALLY COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
WE TOTALLY COULD HAVE
GONE UP THERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> ALEXANDRIA HAS, UH,
NOT BEEN THE MOST POPULAR GIRL
IN THE HOUSE,
BUT THAT DID NOT STOP HER
FROM BUSTING A RHYME
TO KEEP HER SPIRITS HIGH.
>> ♪ I'M NOT A CHUMP ♪
♪ I'M A CHAMP ♪
♪ AND I'M IN IT TO WIN IT ♪
♪ WORD ♪
♪ GOT THAT ♪
♪ NATURAL-BORN SWAGGER ♪
♪ BEST NEVER FORGET IT ♪
♪ WORD ♪
♪ AND IF YOU NEED ME ♪
♪ TO SHOW YOU ♪
♪ WELL, I GUESS I COULD ♪
♪ WOULD BE AS EASY ♪
♪ AS ANOTHER... ♪
♪ DOING THE 'HOOD ♪
♪ PLEASE ♪
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE GIRLS GOT CATTY
AT THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
WHEN THEY POSED
WITH A REAL JAGUAR.
>> MURATO, THERE'S LOTS
OF LITTLE GIRLS HERE.
>> OH, MY GOD. I'M GONNA CRY.
>> YEAH, LOOK, GUYS.
I GOT A LITTLE BABY JAGUAR.
>> OH.
>> LOOK.
MURATO IS GOING TO BE IN
YOUR PHOTO SHOOT WITH YOU GUYS.
>> YAY!
>> OH.
GREAT.
>> (growls)
>> AW.
>> I'M NOT REALLY A CAT PERSON.
LIKE, I HATE CATS.
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY A CAT,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S A JAGUAR.
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicks)
>> (hisses)
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> HANNAH GOT IN TOUCH
WITH HER WILD SIDE THAT DAY,
GIVING FIERCE COUTURE FAUX FUR
IN SHOT AFTER SHOT.
>> THE SHOTS ARE AMAZING.
I MEAN, IT WAS JUST
RIGHT IN THE ZONE.
>> MEANWHILE, MOLLY WAS
SWALLOWED UP BY HER HAIR
AND DID NOT SEEM TO EMOTE
ANYTHING BUT ANNOYANCE.
>> (laughs) WHAT IS HE DOING?
>> AND DALYA OVERTHOUGHT
HER SHOOT,
BECOMING
SUDDENLY SELF-CONSCIOUS
AND STIFF
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
>> IT WAS JUST A STRUGGLE.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
IT WAS A STRUGGLE TODAY.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU.
>> AT PANEL, THE JUDGES FOUND
DALYA'S PHOTOS TO BE
A BIT AMATEURISH FOR THIS LATE
IN THE COMPETITION,
AND SHE WAS ELIMINATED.
>> COMING UP,
THE MODELS ARE STARSTRUCK.
>> AAH! SORRY.
USHER WALKS BY ME,
LOOKS ME RIGHT IN THE EYES,
AND SAYS "HEY,"
AND I ALMOST PEED MY PANTS.
(sighs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MISS JACLYN WAS
A REFINED YOUNG LADY
FROM THE SOUTH,
AND SHE WAS NOT PLEASED
WITH THE MOUTHS OF
THE OTHER GIRLS THIS CYCLE...
>> (bleep).
>> SO SHE TOOK MATTERS
INTO HER OWN HANDS.
>> I CREATED THE SWEAR JAR
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE GIRLS
HAVE VERY BAD POTTY MOUTHS,
AND IT PRETTY RIDICULOUS
SOMETIMES.
>> EVERYBODY'S
(bleep) PSYCHOTIC.
(cash register bell dings)
>> (bleep)
OH, (bleep). WE'RE GOING
TO THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT?
(bleep).
(cash register bell dings)
>> PEOPLE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
(bleep) ON THE (bleep) BED.
(cash register bell dings)
>> (bleep).
>> AND ALL I HEAR IS LIKE,
(bleep) (bleep) (bleep) (bleep)
(bleep) SOMETHING ABOUT CHICKEN.
(cash register bell dings)
>> AND I'M GONNA (bleep)
RUN OUT (bleep) SCREAMING.
>> (bleep).
(cash register bell dings)
>> AT THIS RATE,
JACLYN'S GONNA GET RICH
BEFORE THE END
OF THE COMPETITION.
>> CAN WE SAY (bleep)?
(cash register bell dings)
>> THE GIRLS MET THEIR PUBLIC
AT A FAN CHALLENGE
THAT TESTED THEIR ABILITY
TO MINGLE IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
>> I'M HANNAH.
>> NOW I KNOW Y'ALL
REMEMBER THIS GUY.
>> ARE YOU, LIKE, WEB--
ON WEB SITES?
>> NO.
>> I KNOW PEOPLE HERE IF YOU
WANTED TO DO STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> BUT YOU NEVER SAW
SOME OF THE OTHER
AWKWARD FAN MOMENTS
FROM THAT DAY UNTIL NOW.
>> COOL.
>> WOULD YOU--
WOULD YOU LIKE A PICTURE?
>> ABSOLUTELY. OF ALL OF YOU.
SELL 'EM ON eBay
FOR A COUPLE DOLLARS.
>> CAN I SEE--CAN I TOUCH?
>> YOU CAN TOUCH MY HAIR.
YOU WANT TO TASTE IT?
>> NO, I WAS LIKE...
>> THAT'S A HOT PICTURE OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, I DIDN'T--
I DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS YOU,
ACTUALLY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AS WINNER OF THE CHALLENGE,
KASIA INVITED BRITTANI
AND JACLYN
TO AN EXCLUSIVE DINNER
WITH THE EVER FABULOUS MISS J.
>> (laughs)
>> AND AS THIS NEW FOOTAGE
REVEALS, JACLYN WAS HOPING
MISS J. WOULD PLAY MATCHMAKER.
>> YOU SEE THIS FACE?
I MIGHT LOOK INNOCENT,
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO FLIRTIN',
I WILL FLIRT.
SO IF YOU HAVE
ANY PEOPLE IN MIND
THAT WOULD LIKE A GIRL THAT...
>> NICE SOUTHERN GIRL.
>> I JUST WANT
A NICE, RESPECTABLE GENTLEMAN.
>> WHAT KIND OF WALLET
SHOULD HE HAVE?
>> A LEATHER ONE.
>> (laughs)
>> MEANWHILE, BACK AT THE LOFT,
ALEXANDRIA WAS ALSO SPENDING
THE EVENING WITH MISS J.--
IN HER MIND.
(harp plays glissando)
>> I LOVE MISS J.
I WOULD'VE GOT THERE,
AND I WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE...
OHH!
"OKAY, MISS J., CAN WE JUST
SIT OUTSIDE AND TALK?"
IT'S OKAY.
I'LL HAVE DINNER WITH MISS J.
IN PARIS, WHERE HE LIVES.
>> IT'S REALLY OBNOXIOUS.
UM, SHE NEEDS TO LEARN
TO SHUT UP SOMETIMES.
>> I WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE,
"YOU KNOW WHAT, MISS J.?
LET'S GO ON THE SAINT-TROPEZ
AND HAVE A NICE GLASS OF WINE
AND TALK ABOUT FASHION."
>> SERIOUSLY.
(harp plays glissando)
>> THE NEXT SHOOT
BROUGHT THE MODELS
CLOSER TOGETHER,
AND THEY GOT
A LITTLE DIRTY, TOO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> DO THE BLONDES RULE?
>> YEAH!
>> TOTALLY.
>> FIRST UP WERE THE BLONDES.
>> I LOVE THAT INTERACTION.
GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS.
>> HANNAH AND MOLLY WERE
IN SYNC, AND PRODUCED
ONE SMOLDERING SHOT
AFTER ANOTHER.
THE BRUNETTES ALSO MANAGED
TO MAKE THE MUD
LOOK SEDUCTIVE THAT DAY.
BRITTANI DISTINGUISHED
HERSELF FROM THE PACK
WITH HER EFFORTLESS POSING,
WHILE SEXY MONIQUE
HAD TROUBLE SUSTAINING
HER MODEL PRETTY
DURING THE SHOOT.
>> CHIN UP MORE.
SEE, WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIND
FOR YOU, MONIQUE,
IS THE STRETCH.
YOU'D SEE THIS LITTLE SWITCH
GO OFF--CLICK--
THAT TURNS HER FROM MODEL
TO PRETTY WOMAN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WITH THE COMPETITION
NEARLY HALF OVER,
TENSIONS MOUNTED
BEFORE THE NEXT ELIMINATION.
FOR ALEXANDRIA,
THIS PRESSURE BECAME
A LITERAL PAIN.
>> OW!
I CAN'T STAND UP STRAIGHT.
OH, MY GOD.
CAN ANYBODY CRACK A BACK?
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE HAS THIS BACK PROBLEM,
APPARENTLY,
THAT DEVELOPED TODAY.
>> OW!
(grunts)
>> SHE'S SCREAMING
AND WHINING AND MOANING
EVERY FIVE MINUTES
BECAUSE SOMETHING
HURTS HER BACK.
I'M READY FOR HER TO GO HOME,
AND IF SHE DOES NOT GO HOME
AT THE NEXT PANEL,
I'M NOT GONNA BE
A VERY HAPPY CAMPER.
>> (groans)
>> AT PANEL,
THE JUDGES WERE IMPRESSED
WITH BOTH THE BLONDES
AND THE BRUNETTES,
BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS MONIQUE WHO WAS
NOT STANDING OUT IN HER GROUP,
AND THE JUDGES SAW
A PRETTY GIRL WEEK AFTER WEEK,
BUT NOT ALWAYS A MODEL.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE GIRLS WERE SAD
TO SEE MOMO GO,
BUT THEY WEREN'T DOWN FOR LONG,
AFTER A BRIEF ENCOUNTER
OF THE CELEBRITY KIND
IN THEIR OWN LOBBY.
>> WE JUST SAW USHER!
>> SHH. AND (bleep) P. DIDDY!
>> (screaming)
>> USHER AND P. DIDDY--
TWO OF THE BIGGEST CELEBRITIES,
LEGENDS, IN EXISTENCE.
>> WHAT? WHAT? WHAT? WHAT? WHAT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> AAH! SORRY.
USHER WALKS BY,
LOOKS ME RIGHT IN THE EYES
AND SAYS "HEY,"
AND I ALMOST PEED MY PANTS.
HE SAID "HEY" TO US!
(moans)
>> THE ONLY TOPIC
MORE COMPELLING TO THESE LADIES
THAN DIDDY AND USHER IS
OUR VERY OWN MISS J. ALEXANDER.
(ding)
>> I KEEP CALLING MISS J. "SHE."
>> I DON'T THINK HE CARES,
BUT I THINK IT'S A "HE."
THAT SOUNDS REALLY BAD.
>> "I THINK IT'S A HE." (laughs)
>> WELL, HE ALWAYS...
>> UH, MR. J.--MISS J.
I MEAN--SORRY. EXCUSE ME.
MR. J. OR MISS J.
SORRY.
WELL, IT'S REALLY "HE,"
'CAUSE IT'S MR. J.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> LIKE, HE REFERS TO HIMSELF
AS "BITCH"...
>> MM.
>> AS...
>> I DON'T THINK HE WOULD CARE
EITHER WAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE MODELS COMPETED
IN A PHOTO SHOOT CHALLENGE
SHOT BY NIGEL FOR FORD'S
BREAST CANCER AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN CALLED
WARRIORS IN PINK.
>> WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW?
>> BEATING THE CRAP
OUT OF BREAST CANCER.
>> THE OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT
SUCH A MEANINGFUL CAUSE
AND A NATIONWIDE CAMPAIGN
AND TO WIN A CAR
HAD THE MODELS MORE DETERMINED
THAN EVER TO WIN.
>> OH, I WANNA WIN THE CHALLENGE
SO BAD.
YOU KNOW, JUST THE CHANCE
TO REALLY BE A ROLE MODEL,
IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
WE GOT IT. WE'RE GOOD.
>> BUT WHEN NIGEL DECLARED
ALEXANDRIA THE WINNER
AND REVEALED THAT SHE'D
ALSO BE GOING HOME
WITH THAT FLOSSY NEW RIDE--
A 2012 FORD FOCUS
COURTESY OF FORD--
THE OTHER GIRLS WERE
BEYOND JEALOUS.
IN FACT, THEY WERE PISSED.
>> DUMBEST (bleep) THING
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
>> I JUST WANT SOMEONE
THAT DESERVES IT.
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
>> I DON'T (bleep) CARE
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME.
IT SHOULD'VE CAME OUT...
>> THAT'S REALLY RUDE.
>> LIKE, TEN (bleep) WEEKS AGO.
>> THAT'S NOT NICE.
>> WE DON'T--WE DON'T CARE.
>> WHILE MOST OF THE GIRLS WERE
BUSY HATING ON ALEXANDRIA,
WHAT YOU DID NOT SEE WAS
THE EXTENT TO WHICH
HANNAH WAS MELTING DOWN
AS A RESULT
OF HER CRITIQUE FROM NIGEL.
>> IT WASN'T THAT MEMORABLE
FOR ME.
>> (crying) I JUST HATE
BEING CALLED UNMEMORABLE.
IT JUST REALLY SUCKS.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO
ABOUT BEING UNMEMORABLE?
I KEEP GETTING THAT FEEDBACK
O-OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
IT'S JUST BEEN PISSING ME OFF.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE--
BE MEMORABLE.
I FEEL LIKE WHO I AM
IS ENOUGH.
(groans) (bleep).
(crying)
I DON'T WANT TO BE
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR
IF THAT MEANS
I'M JUST THE GIRL NEXT DOOR,
'CAUSE I'M MORE THAN THAT.
I'M S-S-SO MUCH MORE
THAN THAT, YOU KNOW?
(sobs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE DAY AFTER
THE SUSAN G. KOMEN
BREAST CANCER AWARENESS
PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS' RESENTMENT
OF ALEXANDRIA
WAS AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE
SHE WON A CAR YESTERDAY, DUDE.
REALLY?
>> THE BACKSTABBING STARTED
IN THE MORNING...
>> THEY GAVE HER MORE CHANCES
THAN SHE DESERVED.
>> AND WENT ON
WELL INTO THE NIGHT.
>> IF IT WERE, LIKE,
A LIQUOR AD, I MEAN, OKAY,
SHE COULD BE THE GOOD ROLE MODEL
FOR THAT.
>> THE GIRLS THINK THAT
IT SHOULD GO
TO SOMEONE MORE DESERVING.
QUITE FRANKLY,
THEY DON'T KNOW ME.
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE
GONE HOME THIS WEEK.
>> I'M GLAD BRITTANI
TOLD HER HOW IT IS.
I WAS LIKE, YEAH.
>> I GET A BRAND-NEW 2012 CAR,
UM, FROM FORD.
>> I WAS LIKE, WHAT?!
>> ME, TOO.
>> THAT WAS LITERALLY, LIKE,
EXTRA FUDGE AND EXTRA CHERRIES
ON TOP OF THE SUNDAE
THAT I ALREADY HAD.
>> THAT WAS, LIKE, THE CHERRY
ON TOP OF THE (bleep)-UP SUNDAE.
>> THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT WAS
ON THE UNIVERSAL BACK LOT SET
AT THE NOTORIOUS BATES HOTEL
AND "PSYCHO" HOUSE,
WHERE THE GIRLS
WENT CRAZY FOR FASHION.
>> AAH!
(circus music playing)
>> SWEET LITTLE JACLYN
SHOCKED JAY BY TURNING OUT
A TRULY INSPIRED SHOOT
AS A WOMAN MAD FOR MAKEUP.
>> YOU ACTUALLY KINDA GIVE ME
CRAZY QUITE NATURALLY.
>> ARE YOU A LITTLE CRAZY?
>> YEAH, GREAT. THAT'S GREAT.
>> I'M NOT CRAZY
IN REAL LIFE, THOUGH.
>> "CRAZY FOR MAKEUP."
>> YOU'RE NOT?
>> NO. AT LEAST,
I DON'T THINK I AM.
>> (gasps)
>> MEANWHILE,
MIKAELA'S PORTRAYAL
OF A SHOPPING FANATIC FELL FLAT
DESPITE IT BEING A THEME
ALMOST EVERY GIRL
CAN RELATE TO.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE JUST
LOOKING AND GOING,
"I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO GO FOR."
>> BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
SO MUCH STUFF. EXACTLY.
>> YEAH.
ALLOW THE SET TO SERVE YOU.
>> THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY.
WE'RE GOOD.
AT PANEL,
THERE WAS PLENTY OF DRAMA
DUE TO ALEXANDRIA'S
STILL VERY CONTROVERSIAL
CHALLENGE WIN
AND BRITTANI'S INABILITY
TO LET IT GO.
>> WE ALL KIND OF THINK
THAT YOU REALLY CHOSE
THE WRONG SPOKESPERSON.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IS
PROBABLY ONE
OF THE WEAKEST THINGS
THAT A ROLE MODEL COULD DO.
THE JUDGES WERE NOT PLEASED
WITH WHAT APPEARED TO BE
AN UNAPOLOGETIC ATTITUDE
FROM BRITTANI,
WHICH CAUSED HER TO PANIC
AND FLEE THE JUDGING ROOM.
>> (exhales deeply and sniffles)
>> WHEN IT CAME TIME
FOR DELIBERATION, THE PANEL HAD
PLENTY TO CONSIDER...
>> I VOTE FOR BRITTANI TO STAY.
>> AND I DON'T AGREE
WITH YOU GUYS.
BUT SO DID THE GIRLS
IN THE HOLDING ROOM.
>> IF YOU GUYS DID HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH ME,
YOU SHOULD'VE CAME TO ME.
NO, AND THEN YOU.
WHEN BRITTANI WAS
PUBLICLY HUMILIATING ME,
YOU STOOD THERE
WITH YOUR ARMS CROSSED
AND SMILED, AND THAT'S WHEN
I SAW A DIFFERENT JACLYN,
A REALLY MEAN,
COLDHEARTED JACLYN.
>> COME ON.
>> JACLYN.
>> I CRIED BECAUSE OF HER
THE OTHER DAY.
YOU GUYS ALL WANT ME TO GO HOME,
BUT HERE'S THE THING--
I'M STILL HERE.
I STILL VERY MUCH WANT THIS.
>> BRITTANI FOUND HERSELF
IN THE BOTTOM TWO
FOR HER UNBECOMING ATTITUDE
AND LACK OF GOOD SPORTSMANSHIP.
ULTIMATELY, I WAS OVERRULED
BY THE OTHER JUDGES,
AND BRITTANI WAS ALLOWED
TO REMAIN IN THE COMPETITION
DESPITE MY FEELING
THAT HER ATTITUDE
MERITED ELIMINATION.
I HAVE A SERIOUS ISSUE
WITH HOW THESE JUDGES VOTED.
IT WAS MIKAELA
WHOSE LACK OF INTENSITY
IN HER EYES
AND BLAH PHOTOS
FINALLY CAUGHT UP WITH HER.
COMING UP,
WE CATCH UP
WITH LAST CYCLE'S WINNER, ANN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AFTER THE ELIMINATION,
EVERYONE WAS WALKING
ON EGGSHELLS.
ALEXANDRIA AND THE GIRLS
ALL AGREED IT WAS TIME
TO PUT THE PAST BEHIND THEM
AND TO START
WITH A CLEAN SLATE.
>> I WANNA START BY SAYING,
LIKE, CAN WE KIND OF, LIKE,
JUST CLEAR THE PLATE,
START OVER?
THERE IS A PART OF YOU
THAT I REALLY LIKE,
AND FEEL LIKE
WE COULD BE GOOD FRIENDS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND THEN THERE'S PART OF YOU
THAT OBVIOUSLY... BUT...
>> WHICH THERE'S PART OF YOU
WHICH I HAD NEVER SEEN
YOU EXPLODE LIKE THAT.
>> RIGHT. OBVIOUSLY.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR EXPLODING.
>> THANK YOU FOR APOLOGIZING.
>> ALEXANDRIA AND I--
WE KINDA HASHED IT OUT,
AND I APOLOGIZED
FOR MAKING THE DECISIONS I DID
AND HOW I ACTED.
>> BUT WHAT SHE DID--
ALMOST UNFORGIVABLE.
YOU KNOW, CAN I TRUST THEM?
I'M NOT DUMB.
>> LET'S HUG THIS OUT.
>> BUT I AM A FORGIVER.
>> AND WHILE BRITTANI WORRIED
ABOUT HER FUTURE
IN THE COMPETITION...
PROVE THAT YOU DESERVE
TO BE HERE.
>> I'M REALLY ASHAMED OF MYSELF
FOR LETTING THAT HAPPEN,
BUT I KNOW I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AS FAR
AS THE MODELING PART GOES.
>> SHE FOUND TIME
TO LET OFF STEAM WITH
HER NEW BEST FRIEND ALEXANDRIA.
>> WHAT? WHAT? UH-HUH.
>> UH, MONEY.
WHAT? WHAT? WORK.
>> BAM.
>> MONEY, MONEY, MONEY, MONEY.
>> BOOTY SHAKE.
>> THE NEXT DAY,
I MET UP WITH THE GIRLS
AND TOLD THEM WHERE THEY'D
BE TRAVELING THIS CYCLE...
HI, LADIES.
FIVE OF THEM, AT LEAST...
I NEED YOU TO "C"
WHERE YOU'LL BE GOING OVERSEAS.
>> YOU KNOW,
I'M OPENING MY BOOK.
I'M THINKING, OH, MY LORD,
LET'S JUST GET THESE LETTERS
ON THE GROUND
AND PUT 'EM TOGETHER.
I WANNA KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING.
>> "M," "O"...
IT'S MOROCCO. IT'S MOROCCO.
>> WE'RE GOING TO MOROCCO!
>> GIMME FIVE. GIMME FIVE.
GIMME FIVE.
>> WHICH LED TO MORE BONDING
BETWEEN BRITTANI
AND ALEXANDRIA.
>> WHOO!
>> AND WHILE EVERYONE
HAD TO DECIDE WHAT TO PACK
AND WHAT TO LEAVE BEHIND,
MOLLY HAD A SPECIAL DILEMMA.
>> I WONDER WHAT
I SHOULD DO WITH MY HAIR.
>> SHE'D GROWN
ESPECIALLY ATTACHED
TO HER OLD WEAVE.
>> I BIRTHED A LITTLE CHILD
TODAY.
>> IN THE HISTORY OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
NO ONE HAS EVER HAD
THE HAIR ISSUES MOLLY HAD.
>> TWISTED SISTER?
>> I WAS MAKEOVER DRAMA.
SOMETIMES EVEN
OUR BEST-LAID PLANS
DON'T WORK OUT.
TURNS OUT MOLLY'S
BABY-FINE HAIR
JUST COULD NOT TAKE
THIS KIND OF WEAVE.
>> NO, MOLLY,
IT'S REALLY PRETTY.
>> I'M NOT EVEN GONNA
DO ANYTHING.
THEY BETTER TAKE THIS (bleep)
OUT TOMORROW OR I'M GONNA
(bleep) FREAK OUT.
I WILL CUT IT OUT OF MY HEAD.
MY WHOLE HEAD HURTS.
I WILL RIP IT OFF
OF MY (bleep) HEAD.
AND I AM PISSED OFF.
>> AND WHEN I SAW IT IN PANEL,
I FELT HER PAIN.
NOW, MOLLY, YOUR WEAVE IS
LOOKING A LITTLE CRAZY.
IT'S A WEAVE MALFUNCTION
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
AND, UH, WE'LL--
WE'LL HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT IF YOU STICK AROUND.
WELL, MOLLY DID STAY,
SO WE TOOK IT OUT.
>> (gasps) IT'S OUT.
UGH!
>> AND WHAT DOES THE FUTURE
HOLD FOR THIS BLONDE BABY?
>> I'M GONNA SEND THIS HOME
AND, UH,
HAVE THEM MAKE A SWEATER
OUT OF IT, MAYBE.
>> AND AFTER PACKING
FOR THEIR TRIP,
THE GIRLS WENT ON GO-SEES.
OKAY, SO I AM SO TIRED
OF GIRLS ON "TOP MODEL"
NEVER GETTING
TO THEIR GO-SEE DESTINATIONS.
SO WHAT DID WE DO THIS TIME?
WE HIRED THE GIRLS DRIVERS.
>> I'M ALEXANDRIA.
>> HI. JOHN.
>> HI.
>> HI. I'M HANNAH.
>> WE ARE GOING.
>> AND NOW YOU WOULD THINK
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT THEY GOT
TO THEIR APPOINTMENTS ON TIME,
RIGHT? NO WAY.
>> WHICH WAY?
>> GO THAT WAY. THERE.
(tires screech)
>> JACLYN GOT
HOPELESSLY LOST...
>> WELL, THIS IS THE 101 NORTH.
NO, WE NEED TO GO THIS WAY.
>> BRITTANI, TOO.
>> ARE WE GOING STRAIGHT
OR ARE WE GOING LEFT?
>> WE'RE GOING STRAIGHT.
>> THAT WAY?
>> I MEAN LEFT, LEFT, LEFT.
RIGHT HERE.
(tires screech)
>> (groans)
>> MOLLY JUST GOT ANGRIER
AND ANGRIER.
>> HILL. HILL. HILL.
(bleep), I HATE MY LIFE.
OFFICIALLY HATE IT.
>> AND WHO TRIUMPHED?
ALEXANDRIA,
WHO JUST CHARMED
JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY...
>> IT'S ALEXANDRIA.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> THANK YOU, ALEXANDRIA.
IT WAS MY PLEASURE.
>> AND LANDED A WORLDWIDE
LANA MARKS AD CAMPAIGN.
>> YES!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SOME OF THE GIRLS WERE
DOWN IN THE DUMPS
AFTER THIS CHALLENGE,
BUT ALL OF THEM ENDED UP THERE
FOR THE PHOTO SHOOT,
MODELING ECO-CONSCIOUS DESIGNS
BY MICHAEL CINCO.
THEY SHOWED THEIR GRIT,
BRINGING ATTENTION
TO THE PLACE
WHERE ALL OUR WASTE ENDS UP--
THE COUNTY LANDFILL.
>> THROW THE HEAD BACK.
DRAMA!
>> THIS IS DISGUSTING.
>> BUT ONE MODEL WAS
LESS THAN PLEASED
WITH THIS SHOOT LOCATION.
>> IT SMELLS HORRIBLE.
THERE ARE BIRDS EVERYWHERE.
>> DOES ANYBODY HAVE A BB GUN?
>> THE PROBLEM WITH MOLLY IS,
IS WHAT WHEN YOU BRING
THE CAMERA DOWN, SOMETIMES
YOU'RE GONNA GET A GIRL
THAT'S GONNA BE COMPLAINING,
GONNA BE ANGRY ABOUT IT.
>> THIS IS UNSANITARY.
>> THEN IT WAS TIME
FOR JUDGING.
ALEXANDRIA.
AND WHILE ALEXANDRIA SOARED,
MOLLY'S ATTITUDE
AND JACLYN'S INEXPERIENCE
HELD THEM BACK.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
IN THE END...
MOLLY.
THE JUDGES FELT THAT
FOR ALL HER SOUTHERN SWEETNESS,
JACLYN WAS NOT READY
TO BE A TOP MODEL,
AND SHE WAS ELIMINATED.
FIVE GIRLS ARE LEFT,
COMPETING FOR THE TITLE OF
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW SPEAKING OF WINNERS,
WE RECENTLY CAUGHT UP
WITH CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN WARD.
YOU ALREADY SAW
HER COVERGIRL AD
AND HER "BEAUTY IN VOGUE"
SPREAD IN ITALY,
BUT SINCE WE LAST SAW HER,
ANN WAS FLOWN TO PARIS
TO SHOOT WITH
FAMED PHOTOGRAPHER
ELLEN VON UNWERTH
FOR HER MARCH SPREAD
IN "VOGUE ITALIA."
NOW ANN'S LIVING THE MODEL LIFE
IN NEW YORK CITY,
AND SHE'S JOINED
THE ELITE RANKS
AS AN IMG MODEL.
TO SEE MORE
OF ANN'S "VOGUE ITALIA" SHOOT,
GOT TO vogue.it
OR GO TO cwtv.com.
SO FIVE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
ARE HEADED TO MOROCCO.
WHO WILL WIN IT ALL?
WILL IT BE MOLLY,
OUR ATHLETIC BLONDE
WHO HAS HUNG ON
THROUGH MANY BAD HAIR DAYS...
>> I MIGHT BE ABLE
TO WIN THIS WHOLE THING.
>> KASIA,
OUR FIERCELY REAL GIRL,
WITH MORE EXPERIENCE THAN
THE OTHER GIRLS COMBINED...
>> TO BE IN ITALIAN "VOGUE"--
I WOULD KILL FOR THAT.
>> HANNAH, OUR FREE-SPIRITED
TEXAS GIRL
WHO STANDS OUT IN PHOTOS
BUT NOT YET
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES...
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NUMERO UNO.
>> ALEXANDRIA,
OUR CALIFORNIA SURFER GIRL
WHO IS FREQUENTLY MISUNDERSTOOD
BUT RECENTLY REDEEMED
HERSELF...
>> YAY ME. (laughs)
>> OR BRITTANI,
OUR INTENSE BRUNETTE
FROM A TRAILER PARK
IN PENNSYLVANIA?
>> IF YOU'RE
FROM A TRAILER PARK,
YOU CAN BE ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> ONLY ONE OF THESE GIRLS
WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WHICH ONE WILL IT BE?
>> WE SHALL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
HMM.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS
A MINUTE WHEN "TOP MODEL"
HEADS TO MOROCCO.
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.